hi there today we're looking at fast
reinforcement learning with
generalized policy updates by andre
barretto
shabo ho diana borsa david silver and
doina preco so on high level this paper
proposes a
framework for reinforcement learning
where you have
many tasks at the same time and they
propose a framework
where they learn many policies at the
same time that
can or cannot correspond to these tasks
and then
their argument is that if you now have a
new task that you haven't seen before
you can easily construct a solution to
that task
from your old policies basically mixing
what you learned about your old tasks
and it's a pretty general
framework and we're going to look at it
in my opinion it's
it's pretty cool for certain settings
however
i think it kind of breaks down the the
more general you go which
i guess is expected um of such a
framework
but uh it's as you can see it's kind of
math heavy
but we'll get into the examples and
um what it's potentially useful for
all right so that was it on a high level
if you like
content like this don't hesitate to
subscribe to the channel
and share it out leave a like and tell
me in the comments
what you think i'm still reading all of
them uh
so i will see it
cool let's dive in so they say
the combination of reinforcement
learning with deep learning is a
promising approach to tackle
important sequential decision making
problems that are currently
intractable well they're taking
they're talking about you know things
like um
mostly these game playing ais like go
and things like this so we're this
combination of deep learning with
reinforcement learning has really
shined or shun
whatever one obstacle to overcome is the
amount of data needed by learning
systems of this type
so again if you look at these systems
like alphago
they need a simulator and they need to
collect enormous amounts of
data um even more so with systems like
the dota ai the openai5 dota or
starcraft playing alpha star
i think it's alpha star they need so
many
simulations in order to learn about the
tasks because they always
start from scratch in this article they
say
we propose to address this issue through
a divide and conquer approach
we argue that complex decision problems
can be naturally decomposed into
multiple tasks
that unfold in sequence or in parallel
by associating each task with a reward
function
this problem decomposition can be
seamlessly accommodated within the
standard reinforcement learning
formalism okay so what are they saying
right here
they are basically saying that if you
have a task
let's say you want to get whoopsie from
here
to here and that's very complicated
let's make it complicated super duper
complicated
you can basically subdivide that task
into multiple
subtasks right so here it's like left
turn
right turn go straight left turn
go straight right turn and so on and
each of these subtasks you can see the
two right turns here might share a lot
of
common information there could also be
tasks that
are at the same time like you need to go
forward and
jump can be decomposed into going
forward
and to jump now they're saying is if
each of these tasks
now has its separate reward function in
the environment
like for some reason the environment
tells you
this by the way is task task one
and you're gonna get a positive reward
if you do a right
turn and this down here is task
two the the left turn task and you're
gonna get a positive reward if
for that task so the entire task state
can be decomposed into a vector
so in our case here we have maybe a
vector with
three elements okay the three elements
correspond to
turn right go straight
and turn left and now
your this this right here is your reward
vector so we're no longer talk in this
framework we're no longer talking about
just a reward we're talking about a
reward
vector now each of these tasks is going
to give you
its own individual reward so let's say
you're here
and you're actually turning right this
is going to give you
a reward of one for this task but reward
of zero
for the other task okay
so the environment will somehow tell you
which tasks you
you get reward for now there is a notion
where you can map this back to a single
number
and that is the second thing they
introduce here so the second thing they
introduce here
is this thing they call w so w
is going to be a mixing vector w
is going to be a vector i will call
w right here this is the reward vector w
is going to be the vector
that tells you your final reward so
here we're going to do an inner product
so we're going to transpose this and
multiply by w
and w mixes these rewards and comes up
with your final
reward right here so this this is maybe
the reward vector this is the reward
number how we're going to call this
reward number so
in this case w would have to look
something
like this let's say this is an
example so the task right here would be
to only do
right turns now this is not a really
nice example we're going to see some
nicer examples later on
but you can see that now the environment
is specified as a vector of
rewards and you can create the specific
tasks like turning right
simply by adjusting how you mix these
different things
by this vector w
and this is going to be the key
ingredient here so they discuss
your general reinforcement learning
the reinforcement learning lingo and i
think we've gone through this a number
of
times just very very quickly uh
in reinforcement learning you're given
these
transitions you are in a state you take
an
action and that leads you
to get a reward or prime and
you get into a state s prime in the next
state
they say the reward is given by the
reward function so the reward is purely
a function of where you are and what you
do
and where you get to now most
reinforcement learning problems
you can actually kind of forget about
this part right here
because well it isn't it is kind of
important but you
could um most reinforcement learning
problems
the reward is simply a matter of where
you are and what you do
and this can be a random variable there
can be randomness but
maybe it's easier if you for now think
about the reward simply as a function of
these two
things so what you want to discover is a
policy pi
where you input you input where you are
and the output is going to be what
should you do in that situation
okay uh that is a policy and
associated with each policy is this
thing called a q function
so you can see right here the q function
of a policy
um is going to be a function of where
you are and what you do
and this is a bit confusing but it
basically means that you are in state s
so you are here and you have let's say
three
options action one action two action
to do now the q function tells you
the q function this is s and the a's are
the numbers
okay so let's say we plug in the state s
and for a we plug in number two
what it will tell you is if i am in
state s
and i perform action number two
then how valuable is that for me
and value is defined by all the reward
that i'm going to pick up from now
until the end of time or the end of the
episode
it depends um but let's say until the
end of time
well how much how much reward am i going
to pick up from now until the end of
time
is a bit of a vague not a vague question
but a difficult question
i can tell you how much i could estimate
how much reward i'm going to pick up in
the next step because i know what action
i'm doing i'm performing action number
two
but what happens after that who knows
so that's where this policy right here
comes in
this policy right here says so the full
definition of the q function is if i'm
in state
s and i perform action a right now and
after that i follow policy pi
what is my reward going to be well now
it's well defined so
right now you do action a and after that
you do whatever action the policy tells
you
in that specific situation okay so
that's
the q function and you can pretty easily
see
that if you have a q function right if
you have an accurate q function
you can get a good policy by simply
always going with the action that gives
you the highest q value
because um it's because of a recurrence
relationship called the the bellman
equation uh
this thing right here so your q function
basically decomposes
into the reward in the next step as we
said plus
whatever happens after that and whatever
happens after that is just
by the nature of how the things are
defined is going to be the q function
of whatever the policy is telling you
so you can get a pretty good policy by
always doing
whatever action your q function tells
you is best
this step of calculating the q function
is called a policy
evaluation and this paper here
is going to generalize these notions
um sorry so this is a policy evaluation
and then the
act of selecting an action is going to
be a policy
improvement these are just names okay
but we need to know them because the
paper introduces two
new things i'm going to where do i
highlight policy evaluation
i don't know but here they say this is
the policy improvement
okay ah here policy evaluation
policy improvement these are the two
steps so the first step is calculate the
queue function
the second step is to select an action
and you can see how these things
interlock namely
we can calculate the q function of a
given policy
and we can improve that policy by
selecting whatever
action is best for the q function
this paper generalizes this and you can
see that there is a little
a little r right here so the r
is just a specific way to reference the
reward function used right here okay and
you can see it
here as well
now usually we have one policy and one
reward
right and so what we do is we improve
the policy
and that leads us to better evaluate the
q function for a given reward function
and that leads us to improve the policy
now this paper
is going to transform this into the
following
we have many policies so we have policy
one
policy two and so on until policy
i don't know p and we also have
many reward functions reward 1
reward 2 reward 3 and so on until
reward let's call that r so we have
many different tasks right here
and we have many policies now in essence
they don't need to have some anything to
do with each other for the theory
of this paper but
i can simplify this a bit of how they
see the world
so let's say you have an agent and the
agent
has been trained
on simply that first task right here and
has been trained using classic q
learning reinforcement learning what not
and that results in this
particular policy and then the agent
just from scratch you restarted again
you run reinforcement learning just
on reward number two and obtained
policy number two and so on so you do
this for all these rewards
individually okay so you give the agent
a new task
and you ask it to learn a policy for
that task
now you're in a situation where if you
are
have a new task so are new
the question is do you again
need to train a new policy
and the answer for this paper is no
because we have all these policies we
don't need to train a new we can simply
mix and match these policies that we
already know
to obtain a good solution for the new
task
so how does the paper do it it does it
yeah it does it in the following
it defines the successor features okay
maybe it since maybe it's better if we
first go to an example
so the example they give here is the
following otherwise this
i guess this might sound just a bit too
abstract okay so you have this world
here the agent is the thing here in
yellow and it can just move so its
actions are move
left up right down this this is one step
okay in the environment there are two
different
objects one object is a triangle and one
object is a
square okay so
um there are a number of tasks we can
define
right now in this thing
so we define tasks according to
a reward function so the reward
let's say the reward one is going to be
um one if
if it picks up a square sorry the square
and zero else just if it picks up a
square on any given step we give it a
reward of one
it we don't care about the blue
triangles okay and then reward
two is going to be the opposite it's
going to be
one not the opposite but one if it picks
up a triangle
and zero else so you can see the um
good policies right here so
pi one is a is a good policy for reward
one because it just goes and and
collects these red things doesn't care
about the blue things just goes and
collects them
pi two it goes and collects the blue
things doesn't care about the red things
okay
so let's imagine that you have run
reinforcement learning twice once for
reward one
and once for reward two and
now you have two policies okay so you
have two policies
this will lead to pi one this will lead
to
pi two and now i give you
the third task now the third task is a
bit
special it's one if you pick up
a square and
it's um it's zero
else except it's negative one
if you pick up a blue thing
well the order of these is kind of wrong
but it
just for visual representation okay so
now
you're asked to um pick up the red
things
but avoid the blue things
okay pick up as many red things as you
can avoid the blue things
and again as we said the question is do
you now
have to run reinforcement learning again
in this agent with your simulator using
like
q learning or something like this from
the start
or can you come up with a solution
just given these two policies that will
perform
well on the on this new task
okay and we're going to see
how they do it so what they do
is they use successor features
so these successor features um
i've done a video about successor
features and i'll
link to that you can look at that but
essentially essentially the successor
features are defined
like this and for that we need to know
what this thing is
right here they simply call this a
feature function
okay it's very it's very um
ambiguous term a feature function
is a function that takes in
a transition so state action next state
and maps it to a high dimensional vector
note this is
almost the same as a reward function
except the reward function simply maps
it
to a number now
this is mapped to a higher dimensional
thing
again i wanna i kind of wanna
leave out the next state right here just
to make
things easier on you so a feature
here
can be many many things but the
structure of the
features is going to be such that
the reward function is going to be
this feature times this w
vector so it was a bit a bit not correct
before
when i said the reward is now a vector
the reward
of a particular task w
can be seen as the inner product between
the features
and the task vector so w specifies the
task
and the features well they specify the
features in our case
it can be it can be fairly simple
namely yes i was i was definitely
wrong at the beginning so the feature
functions right here is which
object do you pick up okay so we define
the feature function
as 1 0
if you pick up a square and we define
the feature function as 0 1
if you pick up a triangle and now you
can
and we define it as we define it as
0 0 if you pick up
nothing and now you can fairly easily
see that the reward of each task can be
simply calculated by mixing the features
accordingly
okay so reward one is going to be
simply the feature a 1
0 which is the w vector
so i can specify a task by giving the
appropriate w
vector and now you can see that if this
is my reward function my agent can go
out into the world if it collects
a square it is going to
be rewarded right here if it collects a
triangle even though the features
indicate that it collected a triangle it
doesn't care about it because the w
is 0 right here if i now
want to give it the new tag the same is
true for r2 if and i want to give it the
new task r3
right and you remember the reward
function right there i can achieve that
reward function
by simply multiplying the same features
the exact same feature functions
by this vector right here
okay remember
there is a slight difference between the
reward function and the feature function
in this particular example
the idea of the paper is that the
feature function can be
rich in in expressivity and you know
tell you all sorts of things about
your current state and the reward
function is just a number
right and then the the reward
is specified by simply linearly mixing
these
features so the structure imposed by the
paper here
is that there are such a thing as a
feature
and any task can be described
by mixing these same features okay
that's
that's the issue right here so the
features
are going to be constant
across tasks
whereas the w defines the task
all right so the the goal here is that
if you have
learned many many things um during
your tasks what you want to do is you
want to learn this
feature representation that is the same
across
all tasks and then you want to simply
have the w
specify how to mix these features to get
the reward now of course this is a very
strict very very
definition not not a lot of things will
fall into this
unless you make the features like
exponentially big
of course um however they do
discuss whenever a task doesn't fall
into that
so i hope you're with me so far this is
the first kind of restriction we impose
on our worlds that we can tackle with
this framework namely that
all of our worlds have all of our tasks
in this
world have to be a linear
mix of the same features if that's given
then our um then we can derive
policies for tasks that we have never
seen
we can derive good policies by
doing zero learning simply by specifying
the task
we can have a good policy for that task
from the policies we've already learned
for the other tasks
okay so the reward three is now simply
this and yeah notice it's not the same
as the reward function because the
reward function had
one if you pick up the square negative
one if you pick up the triangle and
zero else so the zero we don't have to
specify here because it's not
part of our features
right so you can see that the reward
function is given simply
by that and
we can now as i said derive a good
policy
for this reward by looking at the other
policies even though none of these
policies has ever learned to avoid
anything
so it makes it defines these
successor features right here so the
successor features
is much like the q function you can see
the signature is almost the same
so as a q function tells you um
how much reward you're going to get if
you do
the action a and then follow policy pi
the successor features almost the same
thing
however it doesn't tell you what rewards
you're going to get
it tells you which features you're going
to get
and which features by that we mean the
sum
of future features now you can see
this some this a little bit this
uh it of course it comes from the fact
of the linearity up here so it's not
really an additional restriction but
simply to clarify what this means for
your
environment your environment has to be
able to be looked at in terms of these
features and these features they need to
be cumulative
again that comes from the fact that it's
linear but to see
so a feature like
i want an an even number
of steps or something like this would be
terrible
uh because and they're going into things
like this later but it would be terrible
because here we have the sum
and um as soon as you if you have a
feature
that is very high if you have an even
number of steps then
um or if you have a feature that counts
the steps
you will never be able to to
do well because if you have a feature
that counts the steps it simply counts
up and up and up and up
depending on how many steps you do and
your reward can never be specified in
terms of a mix of these features
and therefore your successor features
are going to be useless
but in our case where it's where feature
one
is pick up is how many of the
sorry after rephrase our feature one
is whether or not you pick up a square
therefore if we sum it up our successor
feature one
is going to be the number of
this is this is a pound sign the number
of squares that you pick up okay
similarly our feature too is whether or
not you pick
up a triangle in a particular step
so our successor feature number two is
going to be
the number of triangles that you pick up
over time
you can see that the successor features
is kind of the analogous of your q
function
but it is not in terms of a single
number the reward
it is going to be in terms of these
features which is an entire
vector okay and because we've
constructed this in a linear way
you can also pretty clearly see that the
q function
is inherently related to
the uh to the successor features
you can obtain the q function by simply
multiplying the successor features by
your task vector w now a lot of you
might be wondering where does this w
come from and in our initial case we're
just going to
frame everything as being given
right so we're we're given this this w
we're we're defining everything from
our god-like perspective for now so
don't think all of this is learned by
now um yeah
all right so how can you now derive this
this magical new policy okay so we
let's say we have this policy one and we
have the policy two
and they and you have the this features
that you've learned constantly over both
tasks in fact your it's given
right it this pi function we give it
we impose it that the feature one is
whether you pick up a red square feature
two is whether you pick up a blue square
then we know that the reward functions
can be achieved by doing
the w so this here your w
is going to be one zero and your w here
is going to be zero one
and we now we want a good policy for
task
three and we know we can achieve this by
the one negative one
w how can we derive a good policy
and this is this algorithm this general
policy
evaluation a general policy improvement
so it assumes that you as we said
you have many many different
many different policy so here you can
see policy one
where's policy two here's policy two and
so on
it assumes that you have many different
features and therefore many different
successor features in fact you have a
vector of them
right so here you can see feature one
feature two
and so on and it also assumes that
you're in a current state
and you have many actions at your
disposal right now
action one action two and so on okay
so this is all the past you've already
defined your features you have learned
these policies
and now you're given a new w w
new in our case it's this one negative
one
and we want the best action so we are in
state
s we are given this w we want the best
action now here is a method where we can
simply calculate
the best action in terms by by not
reinforcement learning at all in this
new task
so by structuring things like this here
so what does it really
say here it this thing says
we are going to evaluate
all of these different cells of this
tensor right here
so we're going to determine what is the
successor feature
number two for policy pi
one um in state s
if i right now do a2 this is very
abstract so
let's say you're here and action action
two is actually
going to the right okay so you're here
oh this was yellow
it doesn't matter so this is so this is
action one this is action two
so action two is you go to the right
okay you can you can see that this will
let you pick up
um we'll let you pick up a
triangle now here that's action three
and so on
okay so
what's this number going to be so we are
in state s as we said and we do action
two
so action two is going to pick up
a triangle the triangle the picking up
of a triangle
means that our pi for this step
or sorry our five for the step is going
to be
zero one okay so
our successor features this is not the
features itself this is the successor
features the successor features
decompose
into the next step plus
all the next steps that we can follow
okay so all the steps that will come
so what are these features going to be
is it's going to be the sum
over that plus everything that follows
and i can take a little bit of a guess
here
which means that this number so we
only care about feature two right here
this feature
feature two this number is going to be
one for the next step because we are
going to pick up a triangle if we do
action two but then after that we're
going to follow policy one
and policy one has been trained
to pick up the red squares and not care
about triangles
so i'm going to guess that
every now and then it will kind of step
over a triangle but it won't fall we
won't you know explicitly go
look for them so let's say the episode
was 10 more steps but the board has like
100 squares
so and it has like three triangles on it
so let's say that's like three-tenths
um in expectation okay
so this is going to be this is going to
be the number that we're looking for
we're doing this
for every single one of these cells
okay this this thing is going to do for
every single
one of these cells and
this is very similar to evaluating q
functions except we're evaluating an
entire
vector right here that's the difference
to simply learning many q
functions so if you were to evaluate
only a q function then you would only
have this first
matrix this first block right here
okay but you have feature one feature
two
and so on so you calculate everything in
terms of these features
and then by linearity you can mix it
with that vector so in our case this is
going to be the one
negative one which will give you the q
functions right from what we've seen
before you obtain a q function by simply
mixing
your successor features with your um
with this task vector and if you have a
q function
you can pretty easily determine uh which
action you should take
now you have here a q function with
respect to every single policy
but you can simply take the max
right so the max across all of this will
determine
um will determine
so you could take the max across all the
policies
which will give you the q function for a
particular action over
all policies that you consider and then
you can simply take the
arg max of that and determine the action
you should take
okay so it's a pretty big evaluation
but if you do this that means you don't
have to do reinforcement learning on
this task
it simply determines which action
right now is the best given everything
that i know
from these old policies about the task
and that's not going to be like the
optimal policy
uh per se but it's going to be one
policy that's
pretty pretty good and you can actually
prove some
things across that so they do this right
here
and you can see
that here is
what q learning does on this new task of
picking up the squares and avoiding the
triangles q learning
takes a while to get there however
if you do what they are suggesting
and you know you give the w you can
supply the w
almost from the beginning you see right
here almost from the beginning
it is at a high reward now q learning
surpasses it eventually
but um it's pretty impressive
that without doing any learning you
are immediately good right now the
caveat here of course is that
they already need these policy pi 1
and pi 2 given to the algorithm and that
comes from
previous reinforcement learning trials
and they say that
they give these trials as many steps as
q
learning uses so they give them this
these amounts of steps on these other
tasks
so the comparison here is a bit shaky
if you ask me but the point made
is that if you have a new task right now
you can obtain
very good solutions uh and you don't
have to do anything
okay and these solutions can be the
basis for new reinforcement learning
right you could start q learning off
right here
and then get here much faster
potentially and so on
so the next
objective right here is that now we have
defined the tasks and we had we know
what these features are and we know how
to mix these features
as imposers of the task so what happens
if we only have the reward function
we specify the task only in terms of the
reward functions but we're kind of
looking at the features and we're like
agent please figure out yourself how
to to apply these features in order
to make the reward high and that's what
this thing is right here
this gp and gpi with regress w so you
don't
no longer tell it what the w is um
it needs to infer it through
reinforcement learning right
and it's not really reinforcement
learning but what it does
where is it yeah it simply
it because all of this is linear and
this thing here is given so
always remember this thing here is given
and these are the rewards that you
obtain you can simply do a regression
to figure out the w of the task now
that's going to take some
time but as you can see right here it is
going to take
um a lot less time
than sim than doing q learning from
scratch
notably because you have good features
so this is some this is
this gets closer and closer to transfer
learning right
if you imagine that this right here
is your pre-trained neural network and
you simply
learn the last layer of it um
you you freeze this you do transfer
learning fine tune the last layer
here we are so um
it gets closer and closer and you'll see
this trend right here
so it's pretty cool what you can do
but basically i think it's a lot of math
around a framework and the more and more
you relax
the kind of impositions uh that they
need for their framework the more it
gets back to simply
well we do reinforcement learning at
least in
my um estimation so
before we look at that this here is a
pretty pretty cool experiment
where they
they look at how the
how the different tasks can be achieved
if you give different policies so
you'll have noticed that we have always
given these two
two tasks one zero and zero one these
were our tasks that we trained on
and then one z negative one is task we
evaluated on
okay and you might object and say wait a
minute these these two tasks you know
they're pretty
good as let's say pre-training tasks
because
and it's basically the standard basis
right and any other task
can be mixed from those
so these are orthogonal vectors in this
vector space
so you're being pretty generous to this
system
what happens if we're not as generous so
that's what they do here
so they have different um policies and
they evaluate
how much you can learn with these
different policies
so the way you have to read this diagram
is right here
is going to be the one zero axis as they
well they label it right here and this
is going to be the zero one axis and
this is evaluation
so every direction on this circle
defines a task
for example this task right here as you
can see
is going to define the task of picking
up both the squares
and the triangles right whatever you
pick up you get a reward
however the task down here is going to
be
please pick up the squares but avoid the
triangles
at all cost okay and now they're going
to look
what happens if we supply different
policies to choose from
remember we're in this situation we're
again in this situation where we give
everything
and we give initial policies we give the
task vector and now it's about
deriving a good policy just from looking
at the old policy so no learning
as a baseline you have q learning which
into a given direction
um tells you basically how
how long q learning or takes or how
far q learning gets with a given amount
of
steps indicated by this one two three
four
and so on um yeah you see
i think this is this is this in
how far q learning gets with these
amounts of steps is the
dotted lines right here so q learning
gets this far
with 10 to the i don't know 4
and then this far 10 to the 5 and so on
so these are comparisons you can see
that
on the outside q learning is going to
beat this
these methods but our hope is going to
be
that of course if we have this zero shot
generalization it's much better than
running q learning for really long if we
get close to it
so the green thing is what we've already
seen
policies one and two will give you
a fairly you know good um
fairly good extent right here so what
does it mean it means it can solve
it can solve pretty much everything from
here
here this task this this task this task
it kind of falls off once we go down
here
so once we go to the avoid section
it sort of falls off because it has
never learned to avoid
now still we can of course do the
avoidance by simply
imposing a negative collection but
negative collecting
and avoiding aren't exactly the same
thing in these um
in these environments right because
avoiding can also be going really close
to something but not hitting it
while collecting it's not the inverse of
collecting
the inverse of collecting would be like
run away as far as
as far as possible so we can expect that
we've
only ever learned to collect we're not
going to be super good at
avoiding um
then the other
extreme is when we give policies three
and four and i haven't
told you but you can see it right here
uh policy three
is explicitly to collect one and avoid
the other
while policy four is the opposite right
here
avoid the squares collect the triangles
and now this policy
this policy is should be pretty good on
all of the tasks in between as you can
see it has the
biggest extent right here and that also
makes sense by the way
there's nothing down here because the
task of
avoiding both things doesn't really make
sense because you can just
stay where you are because there are
also these
these squares where there's nothing but
you can see
that the mixture of those is
quite potent so already we can see even
though
these span a bases in fact an orthogonal
basis
as much as these because of the nature
of the features that we define for the
task
they are not equivalent in mixing after
so we can be
more generous we can also be less
generous if we
only provide policy five and policy five
is simply to
pick up to pick up both objects
then we're going to have a pretty hard
time when it comes to
avoiding things so you can see it can do
fairly well
picking up the various things in a
positive manner but as soon as we cross
this line
into the like this horizontal line into
where it's about avoiding a particular
object
um it's not it's not the
the choices of actions we have from
policy five
aren't going to be super good
at that
and um they do another they do another
thing right here so that the left thing
is where they say
it's important which policies we provide
and the right thing they want to say
something like
it's important um so
they want to say if we provide
more policies that can be advantageous
because
we basically have more options to choose
from okay
so now they start off with policy four
and policy four is simply
avoid these squares collect the triangle
you can see it performs
fairly well over here where it's all
about avoiding
the uh squares and collecting the
triangles as soon as you get into
you know collecting or even here the
opposite directions
it's pretty bad right that's the red
thing and now they add policy two to
policy four
so policy two is going to be also
to collect um the
the triangles but to just neglect the
squares
and that will also do a bit better why
does it do better
because it's better at collecting uh
because this policy here also needs to
avoid
um and this policy here doesn't care so
in the regimes where it's
better to not care than to avoid adding
this policy adding these options is
going to be good and you can see that
there's a general expansion here
as we add more policies however i want
to point out that
for example here this black thing
which should be technically superior to
the blue thing because it contains as
you can see here
all the policies that the blue thing
contains
plus another policy
um i don't i don't know if my vision but
i'm pretty sure
here the black thing is inside the blue
thing
uh so that means there can also be a
disadvantage
to adding more policies right here
because maybe you got you have too much
to choose from
and so
right here what we say is we add a
policy that is all about
collecting the squares and it is
performing
it is actually decreasing the perform
the addition of this is decreasing the
performance on tasks where you have to
avoid
the squares which
i'm not sure if if that makes sense
again the opposite of collecting isn't
avoiding but
i'm just pointing this out and this
isn't really mentioned in the paper the
paper simply says
see we add policies and therefore we are
getting better i'm not i don't agree
with this given these results or maybe
it the plotting
the plotting is bad all right so
they say okay more policies better which
i disagree with
they also say ho we can
as as much as we can regress the w
right we regress w we figure out the
task we
can even learn the successor features
okay we can not the successor features
um
the pi functions that lead to the
succession successor features and you
can see
if you do it with the true w you're
really good at the beginning
if you do it with a regress w we can see
that before
you can you so this is the small version
of this plot
right here this is like this uh
section i think yeah you know you
improve
however we can also learn this pi
function we can also learn the features
where if we're not given the features
maybe we can learn the features
and they say well we can do this with
but also by regression
so here what we can do is we can find
the function that minimizes the function
and the w along with it that minimizes
this error
right here okay so you're finding the
function
and the w that that matches this error
and this now really is like
learning a neural network i mean
you know um so i get i get it you have
the i
here and the w doesn't depend on the i
and so on
um but
you're getting more and more back to
actually simply learning non-linear
functions
mixing them linearly right here and
i think that's going to be kind of the
crux of this method
uh the fact that the more complicated
your problems are
the less you are going to be able to do
this kind of stuff
and they even go as far as to say well
what if like before
we the reward is actually something like
whether or not you have collected an
even number of triangles or squares
then they say well you can simply not
have a single w but you can find a
function w and now the policy
is a function of the function of w and
you can do
potentially the same regression problem
but
as you can see it gets so now you um
this right here is going to be a
function
of state and
so you can see that it more and more
it simply goes back to basically q
learning again the only difference here
is that you have this
intermediate features but
i think you can simply view this
let's say as a hidden layer in a neural
network
i get it some are held constant across
sums and so on but you know
i i like the method in terms of
um you know in terms of
the analysis so if you are given all
this stuff
it seems pretty cool that you can derive
new policies
uh it's implication for lifelong
learning they say look
here um you have a bunch of tasks in
your
database that you've already learned on
your agent is going out into the world
it faces a new task it can use this
thing
you can use this thing to obtain a new
good policy for that task it can then
use reinforcement learning
rl to refine that policy and then
it can simply save that policy into the
database
so it keeps expanding and expanding
this thing so it keeps adding
rows and rows and rows right here
of new policies that it's learned over
the course of its life so
once it's facing a new task it can just
kind of draw from its experience
and derive a good initial solution
however uh the actual analysis
only works i feel in
quite limited circumstances and if you
want to relax these limited
circumstances then you need to basically
regress and regress and regress
away from away from their setup
and i'm not sure i'm not sure where this
is going to go
if this is going to be a general
framework for people
it seems like it because it's pretty
easy but then also it seems like
most of the world doesn't really fall
into this category
in fact this divide and conquer approach
um
i'm not sure but from divide and conquer
i almost imagine something like
you subdivide and subdivide and
subdivide until
you know you are at some kind of basic
task they still only go
for you know single tasks like this here
the tasks are somehow in
sequence and i'm not
i think we should really think about
hierarchical rl
now this can be a good first step right
here but most hierarchical rl even the
ones that specify themselves
as fully hierarchical like we can do
many layers they
rarely go above two layers or three like
like one one metal layer and one actual
layer
like this one right here uh they rarely
go further
maybe they go two layers but that's
about it
um i've seen very little in actual
hierarchical or dividing conquer
reinforcement learning just because it's
so hard to train
yeah all in all cool paper and
if you want to get it into the math a
little bit i think it's pretty easy math
uh once you kind of set your goals on
what it's actually
meant to achieve um if you just read
from the beginning
all these reinforcement learning papers
it seems a bit like
why why are we doing this right you just
oh
we define this we define that we define
this and
you're a bit like i yeah but why
so often it pays in these papers to go
at the end
to the examples and then uh come back to
the theory knowing what they want to
achieve
all right that was it for me long rant
i'll see you next time bye